this week the National Endowment for
Humanities announced more than eighteen
million dollars in grants for nearly 200
projects nationwide
they include preserving items related to
Helen Keller science fiction author Ray
Bradbury and Hollywood star made west
and one of the projects is centered
right here in New York City it takes a
look deep into Broadway's past to the
earliest days of stage shows on the
Great White Way this is one of the
earlier things from the collection and
this is from 1808 The Forgotten pages of
American theater history this one is
great because it not only shows Edwin
Booth but also his two brothers appear
with him
in this production of Julius Caesar and
his probably more famous brother John
Wilkes Booth performed in this
production in November of 1864 noting
historic tragedies on stage as well as
off hundreds of play bills many from the
19th century now being restored all
thanks to a grant from the National
Endowment for Humanities to the museum
of the city of New York these are the
things that we cared about this is what
we thought was important and it's
interesting to think about that now
because by learning what we valued then
it reflects on sort of how that's
changed all 700 broadsides will be
digitized some will be meticulously
restored we'll have a Japanese paper
rice paper sort of on these every little
tear and that will help prevent that
from tearing further others are too
fragile to be mended they were
originally used to advertise early
Broadway performances including 1866
--is the black crook often credited as
the first musical
[Music]
they also revealed that what passed for
entertainment in the 19th century would
be considered highly offensive by
today's standards some of these shows
are really problematic and some of the
depictions are really problematic
they're their minstrel performances we
have advertisements for TV rice who
originated the Jim Crow character while
they are stark contrast to today's
Broadway play bills they provide a
glimpse into New York's history it's
really part of the vibrancy of an urban
environment and people welling together
and celebrating people's talents and you
don't have to live in New York to enjoy
the project once the restoration is
complete the broadsides will be put on
the museum's website allowing everyone
to turn a page of a New York history you
can learn so much from these ads and the
broad sides that you see you know from
history just 200 years ago I love that
they're saving all this stuff because
this stuff does tend to disappear
particularly because there wasn't you
know there was no real there were no
obviously were no films of it back then
and it's a great record of it